oh I'm going to tell you about my shady
driving history you see because I spent
so many years growing up in England I've
never learned how to drive until I was
20 picked up my first car on my 20th
birthday a used Ford Tempo I lasted less
than six months before I got my first
DUI when I was 20 and then within one
month of getting my license back for my
first DUI I got my second DUI at which
point the car city I wasn't very well
equipped to deal with that second DUI I
couldn't afford the probation costs
couldn't be bothered to take the classes
so instead I moved across country to
live with my sister in Albuquerque New
Mexico and I hid from my legal problems
for a good five years but then I wound
up moving back to Florida squared away
all my problems with the law and I got a
new car a Mercury Grand Marquis which I
wound up driving across country to moved
to Los Angeles in 2001 but in 2002 I got
pulled over in Beverly Hills by a cop
who said I was doing enough wrong with
my expired tags my suspended license my
no insurance that he had to arrest me
but he said he liked me so he got
special permission to arrest me and
release me on the spot he said I
couldn't drive my car though he said
that that I had to tow it so he called
me a cab well when that cab took off
with me I waved at the car wave combines
I knew I was never going to bother
[ __ ] getting that thing back and I
knew I wasn't ever going to bother going
to damn Court which I didn't which is
why I had a warrant out for my arrest
for [ __ ]
seven years man fortunately for me
though there was no warrant out for
steve-o haha
which is why I didn't give a [ __ ] man it
was too important to me to get loaded
all the time to [ __ ] drive so I just
didn't drive I didn't own a car for
seventy years had a warrant out for my
arrest took taxis everywhere cops are
always like so yeah it what's up Stevo
you know like one time I even asked
these cops if they could look up my
warrant they said yeah I dude you're hot
for 10 G's have a good night that was
pretty wild but then I wound up getting
in a lot of trouble going to rehab this
that and once again a squared away all
my legal problems now is when I got my
Nissan Versa a lot of people would think
Steve oh man you could drive a nicer car
than a Nissan Versa but I didn't care
because I wasn't even used to owning a
car at all so I mean [ __ ] I was so happy
with my Nissan Versa drove that son of a
[ __ ] for six years then recently I
decided was time for me to get a new car
I'm not going to say what car I thought
about getting but I will say that before
I got done with the Versa I was going to
be goddamned if we weren't going to make
a [ __ ] video out of [ __ ] as
skateboarders skateboarding all over it
yeah which is what we're the idea for
the skate bonanza
came into play and oh boy did we have
escaped an anthem by the time we got
down to that Nissan Versa I replaced the
front windshield twice the back
windshield once how it doesn't have a
goddamn bumper no more that [ __ ]
thing's [ __ ] but you think I was going
to throw it away
hell no I wasn't going to throw in
Nissan Versa instead I gave it to my
[ __ ] a heterosexual life partner best
friend and Conrad Scott Randolph
international
star yeah a lot of people would say
that's kind of a dick move to beat up a
car like that and then give to your
buddy but I don't see it that way
neither to Scott it's that right Scott
yeah I think I'm told a pretty good
story there where did I leave out oh
yeah
we can't [ __ ] call this project over
with until we get the Nissan Versa and
blow up some damn fireworks whoo the
ceremonial passing of the Nissan Versa
with this artillery shell oh okay you're
the proud owner of a Nissan Versa whoa
oh [ __ ]
fire seriously burning it is good